Russia's FSB Security Service says Wall
Street Journal reporter even gershkovich
has been detained the U.S citizen was
stopped in the city of terrenberg on
suspicion of Espionage according to
State media a criminal case has been
opened against him
his publication has released a statement
saying the Wall Street Journal
vehemently denies the allegations from
the FSB and seeks the immediate release
of our trusted and dedicated reporter
even gerskovich we stand in solidarity
with Evan and his family
joins us now live from Moscow so Dawson
what are we hearing now from officials
in the Russian capital
oh
well we've heard a short while ago from
the spokesperson of the Kremlin Dimitri
peskov who said that the Kremlin is
aware of the Detention of this American
citizen and that he there's no question
of his activities in that region in
Russia the spokesperson for the Kremlin
said that this journalist was detained
red-handed for Espionage and that the
remaining staff of the Wall Street
Journal who are still operating in
Russia are free to continue their normal
journalistic activities we also heard
from the foreign Ministry spokeswoman
Maria zacharova who said that what he
was doing in a katarenberg has nothing
to do with journalism and that this is
not the first time that a well-known
Westerner has been grabbed by the hand
all signs indicating to the situation
that's been ongoing here between the
tensions that have been continuing
between the United States and Russia it
since the special military operation is
it's known here started in Ukraine last
year this example is the latest with the
Detention of a U.S citizen on Russian
soil and claims by the security services
of this country that he was carrying out
Espionage activities at the requests of
the U.S government what the officials
here are now saying is that this is not
the first time and that he was actually
caught red-handed trying to gather
intelligence from a large military
complex in that region in central Russia
and that there's no question of his
intentions now there is the other side
of the story and that is there is a
fixer from that region who is working
with this journalist who said that the
32 year old was gathering information to
do a story about people's reaction to
the Wagner group's involvement in the
conflict in Ukraine so there is the
other version to this story but for the
time being official Sierra adamant that
this U.S citizen was taught red-handed
carrying out sensitive Gathering
sensitive information for the U.S
government okay
reporting that from Moscow thanks very
much dorsa